even with them season my property I
still have to pay taxes James Dupree is
an accomplished artist whose work has
appeared in exhibits around the world
over the past three decades in 2005 he
bought a warehouse in Philadelphia's
Mantua neighborhood and worked to turn
it into a studio my original plans for
the building was a mix you space where
not only could I work here but I would
have a number of other things going that
would supplement my income and also
afford other artists to come here and
work and express their ideas about
making art the building was dilapidated
but Dupree took the risk and said about
fixing it up they hadn't been repaired
in years and the fact that it was so
large an extended a city block it was
automatic love affair where the vision
that I had nobody could see it now
that's all being threatened by the
Philadelphia Redevelopment Authority
through blight they had seized the deed
and title to my property and filed
intimate domain and that they were
taking my property they're supposed to
be charged with redeveloping
rehabilitating inner-city neighborhoods
but the history of Philadelphia's
Redevelopment Authority is really one
that also contains a lot of eminent
domain abuse Institute for justice
senior attorney Scott Bullock is an
expert in eminent domain the
government's power under the
Constitution to take private property
when it stands in the way of public
projects such as building roads or
public schools Bullock was the lead
counsel in the 2005 Supreme Court case
kilo versus New London which involved a
local government seizing property and
giving it to a private developer to
build a hotel complex the High Court
ruled that it was constitutional as long
as the government said they were trying
to increase tax revenues with Aquinas
Realty partners PRA may plans to convert
the blot that Dupree studio is on to a
multi-use area with retail and a
high-end grocery store
well grocery store is just like any
other
business it is privately owned privately
held it is about as far away from a
public use as one could imagine and
there's a question of whether the city
can even get a supermarket to take up
occupancy they said they'd like to get a
grocery store in I in the area but
there's no contract for it there's no
really from my understanding any real
interest from a private parties in doing
so under eminent domain the owner is
supposed to be compensated the city
offered Dupree six hundred and forty
thousand dollars for his property even
though the estimated market value is 2.2
million nobody checked to see the
contents of my building I had went down
the City Hall and filed a complaint and
even with them seizing my property I
still have to pay taxes we got a paper
saying that they were gonna put a lien
on the property that they seized
property owners are treated horribly by
the eminent domain process it is very
difficult to win one of these cases it
is very difficult to pay lawyers in
order to challenge something like this
you very rarely get back what you put in
to the building in the first place and
eminent domain the government holds all
of the advantages fortunately in my
personal case we have found that the
city government has made a major mistake
ironically the inefficiency of municipal
bureaucracy may give Dupree his best
chance of beating City Hall in an
attempt to classify Dupri's property as
blighted in early step at many eminent
domain proceedings PRA ended up
condemning only two of the three
addresses his property sits on Dupree
has started circulating petitions
calling attention to the city's actions
and he's challenging PRA in court a
decision is expected over the next few
months
the one thing that have saved me is the
enormous amount of people they have come
to support me
we now have 2,200 petitions that have
gone directly to the mayor's office
and the council persons office that is
responsible for this